joining us now is tennessee republican
senator and member of the senate
judiciary and armed services committees
marsha blackburn senator thanks for
taking time on
saturday you heard mark meredith's
report there
i just want to get your reaction to the
president
saying that former president trump
should be denied classified briefings
more of the double standard double speed
hypocrisy
that is coming from the biden
administration
and griff this is one of the things that
will remind people why
they did not want more of obama biden
in electing hillary clinton why they
elected president donald trump
and i will tell you this they should say
well should
john brennan should james comey should
others
stop receiving access to classified
information
should former president obama stop
receiving these briefings security
briefings
but you know they've got a double
standard and they're doubling down
on their double standards senator
speaking of briefings i want to turn to
the
issue that for millions of students and
parents across the country it has become
a boiling point and that is the
reopenings you see in chicago
philly elsewhere schools not reopening
because of the teachers unions
now at the white house press briefing
jinsaki was asked
whether or not they would use the
president's bully pulpit to push these
schools to reopen here's what happened
watch
the president is absolutely committed to
reopening schools
he wants them not just to reopen but to
stay open and he wants to do that in a
safe way
and we're going to rely on cdc guidance
which again is not officially out yet
to determine the best way to do it
senator your reaction
well there again double standards the
white house has one opinion
cdc had already said that children could
go back to school
taking the proper mitigation strategies
getting those in place and that is your
ppe
making certain you're using mask you
have dividers
and every the teachers are on the list
for getting vaccinations here's the deal
it seems that the left is concerned
about covet in the classroom
they are not concerned about covet at
the border crossings
and then you have pediatrician
pediatricians
who are saying get kids back in school
look at what is happening with mental
health with teen pregnancy
with teen suicides you need to get these
children
back in the classroom i will tell you
this griff if i were lori lightfoot i
would fire every one of these teachers
that will not go back to school in
chicago
will not go back and teach these
children so senator why won't the white
house
help lori lightfoot and others and lean
on these unions
to reopen you know it's amazing to me
because congress has appropriated get
this
110 billion dollars
to help get these children back in
school in tennessee
most of the classrooms are open our
county mayors our school boards our
school systems
our teachers our parents they're all
working together
to make certain that children get back
to a normal
lifetime a normal school day but you're
not seeing it in these big blue cities
it's why people are getting out of them
as fast as they can
so with the covid relief package which
is moving right down the path
to getting passed with reconciliation
are you calling for
a contingency in that final piece of
legislation
to get that money you have to reopen
yes we have said and i had an amendment
that we filed that said you can't get
these federal dollars
if you are not going to have children
back in those classrooms if you're not
going to have those teachers
in person back in those classrooms
this is despicable that these unions
keep
moving the goal post they are saying
we're not going to go back until you do
this that or the
other and griffith has nothing to do
with the education or the safety of the
children
in the classroom and we know these
children
are learning virtually nothing when they
are
not in the classroom we know their
nutrition is failing
we know there are mental health issues
as i said suicide is up
pediatricians are saying get them back
in the classroom senator
we've just got a few seconds left but i
do want to get your preview
we have an impeachment trial coming what
will happen
in my opinion it is an unconstitutional
impeachment
i think the democrats are now wanting to
get this over as quickly as they can
because they've realized
if they open this pandora's box of a
double standard
again and they are going to try to
impeach
impeach a private citizen former
president
then you can go back through obama
clinton
carter you can go to public officials
like
clinton and comey and strzok and paige
and you can pull them up for impeachment
and they're beginning to realize they
may have opened
a door they did not want to open
senator marcia blackburn thank you for
taking time it's going to be a busy week
appreciate it yes yes thank you